حقيقة أننا لا نعرف ما هو
لا يعني أننا نعرف ما
هو هذا ما ترمز إليه U
لظاهرة جوية مجهولة الهوية إذا كانت
غير معروفة ، فأنت لا تعرف ما هي
[موسيقى]
تحت كل شيء  الظروف التي تحتاج إلى معرفتها
لأنها خصم ، دعنا
نقول إنه روسيا أو الصين ، فأنت تعرف بشكل أفضل
ما هي التكنولوجيا التي يمتلكونها وإذا كانت
أخرى ، فأنت بحاجة أيضًا إلى معرفة أنه
كما لو كان عليك حقًا معرفة الإجابة
واستخدام أكبر قدر ممكن من القدرات العلمية
علينا أن نجعل تلك القرارات
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
خاصة في أوائل الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي ، لقد كان نوعًا من
جنون الأجسام الطائرة المجهولة وكان لديك هذا النوع من
المشاهد الجماعية للأطباق الطائرة والصحون الطائرة ،
كان ذلك في جميع أنحاء وسائل الإعلام والكثير من
تبين أنك تعرف إما
المخادعين أو الأشياء التي تم
شرحها بسهولة ولكن كان هناك نوع من
الضجيج هناك لدرجة أن البنتاغون قرر
البدء في جمع البيانات
[موسيقى]